bonjour merci de nous rejoindre dans
fileco l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
dans l'actualité cette semaine
immobilier d'entreprise le campus du
Crédit Agricole à Saint-Quentin est en
pleine transformation nouveau bâtiment
réaménagement du site la banque affiche
de grands ambitions avec 5000 employés
ce sera le deuxième plus gros employeur
sur le territoire en 2016 le club
d'entreprise fasse la Fondation pour
agir contre l'exclusion fait ses 15 ans
une grande soirée est prévue au théâtre
de Saint-Quentin pour célébrer son
action en faveur de l'égalité et de la
lutte contre l'exclusion ainsi que de la
discrimination d'entreprise enfin nous
découvrirons le succès de la vente en
vrac avec notre entreprise de la semaine
des by day c'est un concept d'épicerie
qui propose de maîtriser sa consommation
en limitant l'utilisation de déchets il
en existe déjà deux dans les Yvelines
enfin à l'occasion de la Semaine des
métiers de l'artisanat organisé par la
Cité des métiers nous recevons Daniel
Varlet Daniel Valère et vous êtes le
président de la Chambre des Métiers et
de l'Artisanat dans les Yvelines nous
reviendrons avec vous sur les
difficultés que rencontre cette filière
notamment pour recruter nous parlerons
des perspectives d'avenir que
l'artisanat propose ce sera aussi
l'occasion d'évoquer pour nous les
problèmes d'image de ces métiers de
l'artisanat qui n'engagent pas forcément
les jeunes à se lancer dans l'aventure
mais avant cela passons en revue
l'actualité de la semaine
aujourd'hui l'association face célèbre
ses 15 ans je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière le club face multiplie les
actions depuis sa création à
l'initiative de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et de la
Fondation agir contre l'exclusion ce
soir c'est l'occasion de remercier les
partenaires et de célébrer la pérennité
de cette association en 15 ans ils ont
accompagné 1200 personnes dont 650
retours à l'emploi durable comme Ronan
Moison parrainé par un chef d'entreprise
il a pu retrouver un poste de technicien
Telecom chez Bouygues
je suis monté très vite en compétence
j'ai eu des formations des
certifications etc et maintenant ça
c'est ma carrière va sûrement évoluer
j'étais assez réservé on va dire et là
maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux ce qui
est intéressant c'est que au fur et à
mesure des années on a eu une dynamique
qui s'est acquit accrue au niveau des
entreprises puisque aujourd'hui on a une
soixantaine d'entreprises impliquées
dans les actions du club donc les
actions du club c'est quoi c'est en fait
c'est le lien école entreprise c'est
l'emploi avec des actions de parrainage
c'est l'égalité de traitement et puis
c'est le territoire où là le club est
parti prenantes dans un certain nombre
de structures au niveau local
le Crédit agricole sera bientôt le
deuxième employeur le plus important de
50 ans en Yvelines alors le campus est
en pleine refonte un nouveau bâtiment
est sorti de terre et le réaménagement
du site commencera dès l'année prochaine
c'est un grand projet pour l'immobilier
d'entreprise sur le territoire mais
aussi pour la banque qui veut ainsi
montrer ses ambitions des images de
William L
sur le campus du Crédit Agricole les
ouvriers s'affairent la construction du
bâtiment Alsace a commencé en mai 2013
20 000 m² pour accueillir 1200 salariés
du pôle paiement la deuxième étape sera
la rénovation des bâtiments champagne et
Provence début 2015 un chantier
conséquent qui va d'abord bénéficier aux
employés déjà présents
donc vraiment une une bonne nouvelle de
savoir que c'était en début 2013 je
crois un programme de rénovation était
lancé nous avons un premier bâtiment là
qui est pleinement transformé le campus
de Saint-Quentin va devenir le pôle
technologique du groupe les effectifs
vont doubler à terme 5000 personnes
devraient travailler sur le campus pas
de plan d'embauche massif les employés
viennent d'autres sites comme Courbevoie
ou Le Kremlin-Bicêtre pourtant selon
Jean-Paul Mazoyer directeur du campus
serait aménagement devrait être vecteur
d'emploi nous concentrons ici à
Saint-Quentin un maximum d'emplois
informatiques quand
entreprises comme une banque emploi une
personne en interne sur l'informatique
en général elle dépense l'équivalent
pour avoir une personne en externe donc
plus on a de monde en interne ici plus
de la même façon on donne du chiffre
d'affaires à des SS2I qui travaille avec
nous l'objectif est de faciliter les
échanges entre les collaborateurs et les
différentes entités du groupe
l'aménagement de l'espace intérieur a
pour but de donner vie à une vraie
communauté au-delà d'être un argument
pour le recrutement l'enjeu est
également d'impulser plus d'activités et
de dynamisme autour des métiers
technologiques l'objectif que l'on a
c'est aussi que ça rayonne en dehors du
Crédit Agricole et de faire en sorte que
autour de nous un certain nombre
d'entreprises puissent également avoir
la même logique somme sur le territoire
de Paris Saclay donc nous avons
également des échanges avec les
universités les grands centres de
recherche faire en sorte que l'on crée
ici à Saint-Quentin un environnement
favorable au métier informatique cette
implication sur le territoire pourrait
inciter d'autres entreprises à
s'installer à 50 ans en Yvelines une
volonté qui pourrait Béné éficier
également au secteur de l'immobilier
d'entreprise depuis 10 ans le nombre de
mètres carrés de bureau sur le
territoire est en constante évolution
les constructions neuves et
restructurées ont-elles diminué de
moitié depuis 2007
Airbus annonce une fusion sans
licenciement les deux filières sous
germa et Aérolia détenus à 100% par le
groupe vont fusionner au 1er janvier
2015 cette Rustica cette restructuration
pardon interne va rassembler 6000
salariés la nouvelle entreprise va
produire notamment des éléments
d'aérostructures ainsi le site
d'Élancourt défense and space n'est pas
touché même s'il pourrait recueillir
certains bénéfices de cette fusion
écoutez les précisions de Jean-Louis
daros délégué
CFE-CGC pardon
chacune d'entre elles est le seul
n'avait pas la taille critique donc le
regroupement de ces deux filiales crée
un pôle aérostructures en France qui va
être le troisième mondial et qui va donc
lui donner une taille pour se défendre
et être compétitives pour notre division
les effets sont un effet d'image sont la
visibilité que des choses industrielles
d'avenir sont possibles ça nous montre
la voie pour ce que nous attendons et un
avenir qu'on attend dans la défense
l'opération collector est lancée en
effet à la commencer hier c'est une
initiative de l'association des
commerçants vicinois elle regroupe 50
enseignes de Voisins le bretonneux et 36
participent à cette première édition
alors l'opération récompense les achats
des clients l'objectif est de faire
découvrir les magasins de Montigny et de
fidéliser la clientèle les précisions de
Estelle Journo la secrétaire de
l'association des commerçants villes
chinois
c'est une idée innovante qui consiste en
fait pour les clients à collecter des
tampons à chaque achat dans les
commerces participants de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux au bout de 12
tampons récoltés le client gagne
d'office une bouteille de vin AOC à
retirer chez le caviste de voisins
et au bout de 15 tampons il gagne la
possibilité de participer à la grande
loterie pour gagner un voyage de rêve à
l'île Maurice pour deux personnes moi je
pense que c'est très bien parce qu'on a
tendance à connaître juste quelques
quartiers on a l'habitude d'aller et
puis ça permet de découvrir d'autres
endroits et d'explorer un peu
le coin quoi voilà
alors l'opération dure jusqu'au 15
décembre et elle a bien lieu à Voisins
le Bretonneau et non pas à Montigny
comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
vous propose tout de suite de passer à
l'entretien de la semaine
je vous le disais en titre nous allons
parler de l'artisanat aujourd'hui pour
cela nous sommes avec Daniel Varlet
bonjour Daniel vous êtes vous êtes le je
le rappelle le président de la chambre
des métiers de l'artisanat alors tout
d'abord pour commencer est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu m'expliquer le principe de
cette semaine qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'il va encore se passer
demain bien écoutez sachez que
l'artisanat est
très fort pour former ces apprentis et
au travers de cette semaine de la Cité
des Métiers la chambre de métiers
en partenariat avec les organisations
professionnelles présentent les
différents métiers pour lesquels les
artisans ont besoin de d'apprentis pour
pouvoir
transmettre leur savoir et créer leur
futur collaborateurs et aussi leur futur
repreneur donc il y a des artisans qui
sont venus des centres de formation
c'est ça alors nous avons des thèmes
bien particulier tout au long des
journées il y a un calendrier qui a été
fait et par thème les
élèves les écoles les visiteurs sont
accueillis par les artisans et par leur
représentation syndicale alors il y
avait un métier qui était présenté
chaque jour est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire un peu quels sont les métiers
d'arsenac qui embauchent le plus ceux
qui sont le plus vecteur d'avenir
tous les métiers dans l'artisanat sont
vecteur d'avenir puisque des difficultés
les gens du bâtiment des difficultés par
rapport à la crise néanmoins et cette
crise qui dure quand même mais
néanmoins ce sont quand même des métiers
et notamment dans le bâtiment qui ne
sont pas délocalisables donc il y aura
toujours toujours à faire dans les
métiers du bâtiment
les formations qui sont qui sont les
propositions de formation qui sont
faites actuellement sur la Cité des
Métiers on leur originalité par exemple
par la de pouvoir visiter les
entreprises
nous avons vu nous avons organisé des
visites dans les entreprises pour les
jeunes afin qu'ils connaissent les
entreprises intéressent le plus les
jeunes et ce qui veulent plus travailler
en tant je ne sais pas boucher cuisinier
alors il y a des entreprises qu'on qui
ont plus de succès en ce moment par
rapport à certaines métiers de
cotisation qui sont faits à vos
collègues
dans la dans la boucherie par exemple on
a beaucoup recruté cette année depuis
deux trois ans en boucherie mais si on a
doublé les capacités d'accueil pour nos
jeunes
la restauration a quand même du mal on
recrute encore des jeunes dans la
restauration puisque les jeunes ont des
un petit peu de souci par rapport aux
horaires
s'impliqués dans les entreprises vu le
timing qu'il aurait donné ils doivent se
couper de leur relationnel jeunes leurs
copains leur rythme scolaire sont
vraiment différents donc on a beaucoup
de de jeunes qui essayent la
restauration sans trop bien savoir ce
que c'est mais malheureusement n'y reste
pas par les contraintes des contraintes
de de vie quotidienne
est-ce que aujourd'hui voilà c'est
encore possible pour un jeune qui veut
se lancer dans l'artisanat de devenir
son propre chef d'entreprise que c'est
un rêve que promet l'artisanat c'est
toujours possible aujourd'hui absolument
vous savez chaque chaque semaine nous
faisons des stages de préparation à
l'entreprise que bien souvent nous nous
allons nous présenter en tant qu'artisan
auprès de ces gens pour témoigner de
notre de notre passage dans l'artisanat
et c'est toujours plaisant de voir ces
jeunes qu'on des envies des volontés et
sont par passion aussi et on leur dit du
travail bien fait dans l'artisanat c'est
ces gages de réussite il y a aucun
problème et pourtant la filière a
vraiment des difficultés à recruter
combien combien de d'artisans m'ont par
exemple dans les Yvelines combien il en
manque dans les Yvelines ou en France
alors on peut on peut dire qu'il nous
manque 50 000 apprentis sur l'ensemble
du territoire alors
et le manque n'est pas tout à fait
pareil dans chaque sur chaque territoire
par rapport à l'activité artisanale
cependant ce manque amplifie d'année en
année parce que malgré tout le bien
qu'on peut porter à l'artisanat puisque
on compare l'artisanat de l'Allemagne à
l'artisanat en France sachez qu'on perd
10%
d'apprentis chaque année depuis 3 ans on
rentre 10% en moins d'apprentis dans nos
centres de formation
est-ce que l'artisanat a un problème
d'image ce qu'elle souffre d'une
mauvaise image c'est vrai que vous avez
au final du mal à recruter des jeunes
artisanat a évolué maintenant on a envie
d'être
on a envie d'être artisan et même les
parents donnent
donne l'envie à leurs enfants
désireux d'aller vers des métiers comme
ça vous savez quand on voit la réussite
professionnelle dans l'artisanat
on se pose des questions par rapport à
les dents du tertiaire ou faire des
études nous on commence à la base du
métier et puis on fait une c'est un
ascenseur social pour nous
50% des artisans ont été formés par
l'apprentissage en alternance en étant
immergé immédiatement dans l'entreprise
donc il y a quand même de la réussite
sachez aussi qu'un apprenti 8 apprentis
sur 10 ont un emploi pérenne à l'issue
de leur cursus donc
c'est pas il y a un problème justement
voilà d'image comme je vous le disais
enfin
l'image évolue il y a peut-être des gens
qu'on peur de s'investir dans
l'apprentissage mais je peux vous dire
ceux qui commencent dans l'apprentissage
et qui réussissent c'est un vecteur
formidable si on connaît peut-être moins
bien les métiers que que qui sont dans
la tisane qui sont dans l'artisanat
alors on a des métiers traditionnels le
bâtiment les services les métiers de
bouche mais on a aussi des métiers tout
à fait innovants dans les technologies
modernes dans la recherche l'artisanat
est à la base de l'innovation
technologique donc quels sont ces
métiers par exemple qui pourraient
intéresser certainement les jeunes
aujourd'hui vous avez tout plein tout
plein de métiers bien spécifiques des
niches
hier c'est un jeune qui fait de la
géolocalisation pour pouvoir savoir ce
qu'il y a comme tranché pour après venir
directement avec des gros bulldozer donc
il m'a dit que ça c'était un marché
c'était une niche et il y a un marché à
développer mais vous savez c'est 250
métiers l'artisanat donc c'est vaste et
du coup on c'est une formation qui
commence très jeune on parle de tête
d'en parler avant le collège avant la
troisième est-ce que ça vous semble un
peu tôt ou est-ce que ce serait une
bonne solution pour justement attirer
plus de jeunes car la tisane
alors dans l'artisanat on a maintenant
deux sortes de personnes parce que on
s'aperçoit aussi que les diplômés des
gens de des gens de 20 ans des gens de
25 ans reviennent dans aussi dans
l'artisanat parce qu'ils avaient un
projet initial
de s'installer et puis les parents ou
pour des choses ils ont fait des études
et ils ont pas forcément réussi dans
leur domaine donc on ouvre des
formations dans l'artisanat déjà pour
des formations adultes
et puis aussi pour les jeunes dès qu'on
commence à 17 ans dans l'artisanat vous
vous progressez vous progressez c'est et
vous apprenez au fil du temps et vous
pérennisez quand même le geste et le
savoir-faire de l'artisan est-ce que
vous sentez épauler par le gouvernement
parce qu'il y a quelques semaines il y a
une réunion d'informations sur
l'apprentissage parce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement peut faire plus pour
vous et pour pour aider justement ce
secteur à se développer
je pense que faut mettre en valeur nos
jeunes qui sortent de l'apprentissage je
pense qu'il faut identifier les maîtres
d'apprentissage car c'est vraiment des
valeurs sûres il faut reconnaître tout
ce monde qui représente 10% de
l'économie nationale et il faut les
mettre en valeur pour savoir si on est
toujours malgré la crise on embauche
toujours 100000 personnes dans la dans
l'artisanat par an je vous propose de
passer maintenant au chiffre de la
semaine
alors le chiffre de la semaine concerne
également l'artisanat
18512 c'est le nombre d'entreprises
artisanales dans les Yvelines ce nombre
peut paraître important pourtant le
département se retrouve en
avant-dernière position dans le
classement des départements de
l'Île-de-France l'Île-de-France elle
compte
186582 entreprises artisanales le
secteur le plus important est celui de
la construction avec près de 75 000
entreprises dont plus de 7000 dans les
Yvelines est-ce que vous avez une
réaction par rapport à ça monsieur
Varlet non tout à fait normal c'est par
rapport à la topologie du terrain qui
fait que on a la plus grosse
concentration d'artisan séparée après je
crois que c'est le 93 on est allonnés
par le 95 qui sonne tout on est à peu
près les mêmes le nombre d'artisans puis
le 77 qui est 50% du département
Île-de-France au point de vue de
superficie là où il y a aussi beaucoup
d'artisanat et c'est simplement par par
le fait de la concentration d'activités
qui est tout à fait différente d'un
département à l'autre et bien merci
Daniel Barlet d'être venu sur notre
plateau il est temps maintenant de
découvrir le zoom métier de la semaine
et nous restons dans le domaine de
l'artisanat notre zoom de la semaine est
consacrée au métier d'ambulancier et ça
peut paraître étrange mais les
ambulanciers auxiliaires donc bulance
sont considérés comme des professionnels
de l'artisanat c'est le cas lorsqu'ils
travaillent pour des sociétés de
transport privé c'est un métier mal
connu pourtant vous allez le voir il
recrute comme l'ont découvert Elodie
moine et Claire Cambier
qui a une altération de l'état général
donc ça peut tout dire et rien dire donc
le tout c'est d'arriver sur place assez
rapidement et puis ensuite établir notre
bilan clinique garder son calme même
dans l'urgence le quotidien pour ses
ambulanciers disponible 24 heures sur 24
ils sont le relis du Samu une fois sur
les lieux de l'intervention il faut
faire preuve d'un grand sens de l'écoute
face à des personnes souvent inquiète
par exemple plus pour aller faire un
tour à l'hôpital voir ce qui se passe
mieux vous allez reprendre des forces
surtout passe par là une bonne
alimentation ça doit être plus de force
et le meilleur défense pour votre corps
mobile et autonome le métier
d'ambulancier est un métier physique où
les heures supplémentaires sont monnaies
courantes en plus d'être bon conducteur
aimer les rapports humains est
essentiels la communication c'est
vraiment très très important lors d'un
transport surtout quand il y a quelqu'un
qui agitait et c'est de le calmer
de parler c'est très très important
Xavier a fait son apprentissage dans
cette société d'ambulance artisanale
qu'il a embauché par la suite à 1800
euros net Pascal Lequin fait le gérant
ambulancier depuis 36 ans il a ouvert il
y a 7 ans une société d'ambulance légère
contrairement aux véhicules lourds ses
ambulances ne prennent pas en charge les
urgences mais font de l'accompagnement
en consultation et lieu médicalisé
l'ambulance légère c'est de
l'enchaînement permanent toute la
journée donc il est clair que quand on
perd du temps dans un embouteillage ou
quand on est ralenti par par la
pathologie d'un patient il faut s'en
occuper un peu plus longtemps et bien il
est sûr que c'est plutôt ce stress de
planning avec des gens qui nous
attendent l'autre bout du département
qui qui est le plus dur à gérer en fait
difficile de recruter avec ce rythme
soutenu car en société regroupant 1000
ambulanciers sont en exercice dans les
Yvelines mais ce n'est pas suffisant la
profession cherche à créer des vocations
en faisant découvrir le métier
qui va nous permettre de transporter des
personnes âgées qui sont tombées chez
elles et qui ont une forte douleur
notamment au niveau du racisme au niveau
du au niveau du col du fémur aussi c'est
une profession qui est inscrite au Code
de Santé publique au même titre qu'un
infirmier qu'un médecin ou quelqu'un qui
kinésithérapeute la formation dure 630
heures et dans la formation on retrouve
effectivement de l'anatomie de la
physiologie des gestes d'urgence mais
également comment on examine un malade
c'est un secteur qui a des difficultés à
recruter des personnels parce que
effectivement les conditions de travail
peuvent être difficiles on travaille la
nuit on travaille le week-end et jours
fériés avec des plannings qui évoluent
au fur et à mesure au fur et à mesure
des missions une centaine d'ambulanciers
est formé chaque année dans les Yvelines
90% d'entre eux trouvent en emploi dès
l'obtention de leur diplôme
consommer responsable et lutter contre
le gaspillage ce sont des des concepts
innovants qui séduisent de plus en plus
les consommateurs l'entreprise de la
semaine l'a bien compris elle propose
des by day pardon c'est une franchise
d'épicerie en vrac implantée à
Versailles et Fontenay-le-Fleury elle
propose de maîtriser son alimentation sa
consommation tout en réduisant
l'utilisation de déchets souvent
inutiles des images signées Élodie
moines
alors je peux vous renseigner oui il me
parlait des copeaux oui il y a les
novices c'est les connaisseurs pierre et
de cela depuis qu'il a découvert cette
épicerie en vrac il est l'un de ses plus
fidèles clients soucieux de
l'environnement ils seront toutes les
deux semaines à la boutique de
Versailles avec ses propres sacs
plastiques pour faire ses courses on
essaie de faire quand même attention à
la planète tout ce qui est à côté et en
même temps ça permet ici d'acheter en
vrac d'acheter vraiment le produit et
pas l'emballage qui me sert à rien par
la suite
farine sucre huile des produits
essentielles du quotidien sont
disponibles l'épicerie propose même des
produits ménagers à remplir directement
dans d'anciens flacons des bocaux en
verre sont également mis à disposition
pour les clients moins d'emballage donc
moins de déchets et cela se ressent sur
le budget ça vous fait un total de 45
euros 26 par carte
meilleur et moins cher 45 euros pour
deux semaines c'est
emballage les produits sont vendus entre
5 et 20% moins cher l'épicerie de
Versailles est ouverte depuis le mois de
mai c'est la deuxième franchise du
groupe elle attire entre 200 et 300
personnes chaque semaine des débuts
prometteurs le fait de pouvoir se servir
soi-même les gens ont l'impression de
jouer à la marchande un petit peu le
côté sans emballage effectivement je
suis assez contente d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai converti pas mal de clients qui
n'étaient pas du tout
vraiment intéressé par
le problème des déchets et qui
finalement se sont mis à vraiment faire
très attention chez eux derrière ce
concept innovant deux associés issus de
la grande distribution et du marketing
l'idée est née dans les années 2000 mais
ils l'ont concrétisé il y a seulement
trois ans
250.000 euros leur ont été nécessaires
pour démarrer l'aventure avec une
première enseigne une plateforme
d'approvisionnement et des stocks
on a choisi le mode de développement en
franchise parce que on cherche un
développement qui soit relativement
rapide partagez avec des gens qui ont
envie de faire la même chose aussi
encore une fois il est pas question de
venir des grands promoteurs immobiliers
qui aurions nous-mêmes 500 boutiques
sous notre gestion ça n'a aucun intérêt
en revanche on peut partager avec plein
de gens et on a beaucoup de candidats à
la franchise bien qu'on est très peu
communiqué pour l'instant on a surtout
bien appris à faire bien notre métier
l'ouverture d'une franchise demande un
investissement de 60000 euros l'enseigne
prévoit d'ici fin 2018 l'ouverture d'une
centaine de boutiques principalement en
Île-de-France
et nous terminons cette émission par
l'agenda de la semaine voici deux
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer mardi un
petit déjeuner d'entreprise est organisé
avec le Medef Yvelines à la Maison de
l'Entreprise de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le rendez-vous
est fixé de 8h30 jusqu'à 10h au
programme débat et conférences sur le
thème des documents contractuels pensez
à réserver votre place comment valoriser
vos compétences vos expériences
professionnelles en adéquation avec les
besoins des entreprises lorsqu'on est
demandeur d'emploi de plus de 45 ans si
vous vous êtes déjà posé cette question
venez mercredi à la Cité des Métiers de
Trappes le club face anime un atelier
sur ce thème de 9h30 à 12h30 n'oubliez
pas de vous inscrire
merci de nous avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
prochain rendez-vous de Philippo je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée